the Joe Rogan experience what's really
hard to be unbiased it's really hard to
just have an unbalanced perspective and
I don't think anybody does a good job as
president I've never seen a single
person do it well I've seen Obama give
very good speeches I think he's very
statesman like I think he's very what
Obama did that was a was excellent was
he was very composed and articulate and
smooth and he represented a highly
educated like a high level of human
being in terms of his intellect and the
way carries himself and I think that
that's good for the country you know but
I think the way you look at the drone
attacks look at the attacks on on
whistleblowers and on the press and
there's a lot of bad [ __ ] about the
Obama administration that everybody
wants to sleep in front of the rug
because I think nobody's a good
president I think it's a terrible job
that it I didn't like how he he sort of
started a war on cops you remember when
he was you know crucifying some of the
arrests they had and it started people
were looking at cops think these a good
guys are the bad guys I didn't like that
because maybe there are some bad cops
but there's bad everything you do every
job has bad whatever so instead of
highlighting the people out there
protecting our interests and serving the
public he was highlighting the quote bad
cops I guess and it and put them all in
a bad light I didn't like that whereas
Trump he knows you know he's
highlighting good police work he's
highlighting the military he's you know
pride in in the good old United States
of America I like that so I mean I don't
know yeah well the thing that drove me
nuts the most nuts about Obama was that
crazy speech that he said if you have a
business know the highway you didn't
build that yeah you didn't build that
business you didn't build that like that
- yes ma'am that is the craziest way to
look at things yeah
if I was his friend I would said okay
this is not the way to say no what he
did I think he started like highlighted
the victim mentality everybody's a
victim whereas I like Trump he says
you're
control here's your opportunity make the
most of it I was afraid very differently
I would have said if you have a business
and you start it yourself
congratulations this is what American
ingenuity is all about but we all have
to be aware not just you not singing
that person huh you didn't know that
yeah who didn't do it I would say we all
have to be aware of that without our
infrastructure we would none of us would
be able to do right so we all have to
support this beautiful system right yeah
so in an empowering way instead of you
didn't do it you didn't build it yeah
you didn't do it
taking credit away from people who work
their ass off totally and by the way
he's guy who's never been in business
right just he's a lawyer he went from
being a lawyer to being a professional
politician to being the president
yeah and bamm-bamm messes that's one
thing I don't like is people who are
like their goal is to be a politician
well I don't like that I'd like it if
they were awesome at it but no this is
not I like it seems like the best like
even back in you know that you know when
our country was founded it those weren't
politicians those were guys who had
influence who made good decisions and
then they were politicians you know what
I mean
I've been watching Vikings a lot lately
it's new show I've been watching okay
and it seems like there's no good
leaders in the Viking world there was
bad leaders this leader suck nobody
wants nobody wants a goddamn leader and
when you're a leader of 350 million
people or whatever the hell you have
here tough it's just impossible doesn't
make sense what's going on Jamie I just
looked up that quote out of context but
he said it he said those two sentences
but not in that way oh if you got a
business you didn't build that hey you
know it's fake news okay so what is the
actual quote it's weight I mean here's
the let's hear the real quote mm-hmm
have you were successful somebody along
the line gave you some help
there was a great teacher okay but what
is it if you've got a business you
didn't build that okay somebody invested
in roads and bridges okay here it is
somebody helped create this unbelievable
American system that we have allowed you
to throw that have a that we have that
allowed you to thrive yeah somebody
invest in
roads and bridges if you got a business
you didn't build that that's just a [ __ ]
way to say it it's care even in context
sometimes that happen
yeah not somebody else we all chipped in
did some real I know that's what he's
saying but it's a [ __ ] way to say it
it's a [ __ ] disempowering way to say it
is that's what I don't want takes credit
away from the label it's there's a way
to do that there's a way to phrase that
that needs an edit and rewrite and by
the way how the [ __ ] could he even have
time to do that when you're writing I
mean you're writing under the pressure
of being the president United States I
totally sympathize I get it I'm not
saying I would have done better I would
have done way worse but it still sucks
yeah it's just not a good way to say
things I know that I don't what you said
you said disempowering and yeah that's
exactly right and so it feels like this
is there's a different tone right now
and I'm not saying you know our
president is perfect you say it white
people you like but I'm just saying
nobody's perfect but I like that part of
the message yeah well he definitely has
that part of the message but he's
obviously said a bunch of stupid [ __ ]
too but he's also a guy who flies off
the cuff I mean this you we have to take
into consideration what this guy was his
entire career he's a giant
larger-than-life personality with crazy
hair who puts his name on everything
yeah and then he ran for president oh
yeah of course he's gonna stay that guy
when he becomes president we gonna know
now that you're president it's like when
you when you're in if you're playing
Beauty and the Beast and you're the
Beast you gotta act like the Beast now
you got the role Yeah right
why you still acting like you grant yeah
you know you can't I know and it's the
role of being the president is this you
know this majestic top of the mountain
that we look at like oh he's the guy
he's the main dude yeah you're supposed
to act like the president like that's
what they say he's not presidential
exactly
[Applause]